let's talk next via discord to
let's go to kyoko from japan what is it
there
9 30 in the morning hi
hello hello hi you're on the air yes i
can hear you
okay well you know what um i think uh i
have to connect
to my earphone because i can't hear your
voice very well
by all means make to the earphone that's
fine are you is it 9 30 in the morning
there
uh it's 10 30. 10 30 in the morning oh
my god
oh right 14 hours okay that makes sense
right
wow i've been a big fan of yours for
years
thank you yeah it's it's great i mean
wow it's so exciting i'm pretty sure
you're our first japanese caller kyoko
oh really yeah wow it's so exciting yeah
i'm working from home and my husband is
also working from home
beautiful so you know i just found some
time okay this is
yeah well that's uh great so i thank you
so much um
oh i really appreciate you know
uh what you do and uh i i don't have any
particular question but i'm wondering
if you have any question about like you
know what's going on in japan
oh i have so many questions kyoko it's
so great that you called in
here's what i want to know i know that
so many neighborhoods in japan
are known for these really small
restaurants you know eight seats 10
seats 12
seats are they totally shut down because
of the virus or are they open
i lost you okay oh boy
yes yes please okay the small
restaurants the eight and ten seat
restaurants that tokyo and other parts
of japan are known for
have they been able to remain open
during the pandemic or have they had to
close
uh well they were open and then
currently we are um
under uh state of emergency once again
yeah they don't call it a lockdown just
a state of emergency just
requesting government requesting those
uh restaurants
to close at eight o'clock okay for
currently for four prefectures
prefectures are like a state yes united
states
so yeah four four big prefectures
including of course tokyo
and you know surrounding prefectures
they're they're close they they are
requested to close at
eight o'clock so you know those small
restaurants as you know
yeah they are known to serve alcohol and
then the government think it's
the wrong this is the risky situation
where people get together
right they stay longer they they tend to
drink a lot and then they talk a lot you
know
so they consider it's a very risky
situation and so they
but before eight before 8 pm k
if you have a 10 seat restaurant all 10
seats can be filled
uh yeah wow that seems dicey yeah
i know i know but the problem is that
the people are complaining that people
working at you know you know after the
office hours if they want to eat
something before going home
right you know by the time they reach to
those small restaurants
they're all closed right they have to
rush in
maybe you know before eight o'clock you
know just they just pack into those
small restaurants
just before the closing time right and i
consider it's risky and also they go to
convenience stores there are tons of
convenience stores in japan
which are open for 24 hours so they rush
there
and then they get something to eat now
i've heard that i've heard that the
sushi at the convenience stores isn't
bad
yeah it's uh sushi i don't know i never
bought sushi
okay um convenience fair is quite good
that's fair that's fair is your husband
what we would call a salary man
oh yeah he's a typical salary man and
he's an
indian so he can even talk with you in
english
but he's from india he's from india but
he lives in japan
yes okay here for 17 years wow married
for 10 years
yeah this is it now let me ask you one
other question
do you ever make a homemade miso soup
oh yes when you make the miso soup do
you
use the fish flakes in making the dashi
yes it's a combination usually we use
bonito flakes yeah and also you can
mix with the um mushroom shiitake
mushroom
really mushroom yes so does anything
you know induce what you call umami you
know that amino acid
yeah you can mix the vegetable-based
broth in the
so in other words you're making you're
making your dashi with the bonito flake
the kombu
and shiitake mushroom wow so you can
yeah you can
uh find any other other like uh
dried fish also like sardine or you know
uh yeah that's a revelation kiyoko that
you're that's that's stunning
and and then if you are good then you
should if you're a good housewife or
some somebody
who are into cooking you're supposed to
make your own
broth but you know because uh now that's
interesting
is it is it considered culturally um
is it considered not masculine for the
man to make the miso soup in japan
well you know um it's changing you know
nowadays the guys of course i mean you
can see on the youtube even
like uh um you know people even men
open those cooking channels and then
right it is it is really
becoming known but again you know if you
talk about my
father's generation my father never
cooked anything except
maybe sunny side up interesting
interesting
well kyoko it's all it's all fascinating
you're really blowing my mind here i'm
curious where did you learn such great
english
oh thank you oh well now i
i haven't lived abroad but i'm working
as an interpreter now i really love
english and then you know since i was
kid um
i try to get any you know possible
chance to
listen to english and then you know
finding a channel like you is also one
of my
favorite activities and i was so excited
when i found you
and even though oh i don't really um
i don't really care about japanese
politics but i'm interested in american
politics so yeah i was very happy to
find you
well i really appreciate the call yeah
continue yeah thank you i continue to
support you as much as i can
so really exciting do you um
last question have you taken up a
position
yet uh on the toontoon
channel and whether he should continue
doing thai cooking or go japanese
well i love thai cooking so because i am
not stick to a japanese cooking
my husband also he's not into any indian
cooking or whatever
whatever we we just love eating so
okay i yeah i go out to eat you know
even the during the long time i'm in a
state of emergency
yeah we continue to eat like you know on
weekends but
of course um after taking all the
precautionary measures so well kyoko
you've said it all you are our first
japanese caller and our best japanese
caller and i hope to hear from you again
yes sure thank you so much david and uh
please uh
take care of yourself all right you too
uh
wow i mean it's a perfect phone call
guys
it's i don't know i we've now i don't
know that we've had anything like it
um we are going to have to clip that and
publish that during our
vacation absolutely perfect phone call i
predict no
investigations as a result of that
today's episode is sponsored by
bluechew a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month's supply for
free take a short quiz on the chew
website
a licensed doctor approves your
prescription and the medication goes
right to your home in a discreet package
no driving to the doctor's office
having a possibly awkward conversation
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluechu replaces the entire process with
a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
bluetooth tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
go to bluechew.com the link is under
this video and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for
free when you use promo code pacman just
pay five dollars for shipping